the u.s has long accused china of cyber
spying but it's never made those
accusations official in a court of law
until now attorney general eric holder's
message enough is enough this
administration will not tolerate actions
by any nation that seeks to illegally
sabotage american companies and
undermine the integrity of fair
competition in the operation of the free
market
this case should serve as a wake-up call
to the seriousness of the ongoing cyber
threat
the indictments are against five members
of the chinese military they allegedly
spied on six u.s companies including
nuclear power plant builder westinghouse
and alcoa the largest american aluminum
company
the u.s says the alleged spying gave the
chinese companies unfair advantages in
the market
the chinese foreign ministry quickly
rejected the charges and said the case
would harm u.s chinese relations
china is a staunch defender of network
security it said in a statement and the
chinese government military and
associated personnel have never engaged
in online theft of trade secrets
the charges against the six defendants
could carry decades in prison
but they're all at large in china and
the u.s acknowledges there's virtually
no chance of them being extradited